[Music]
what i had realized for myself is not
that i can't take
time off or that i can't
i can't ignore the inbox or refuse to
reply on
the vast majority of things that come in
what i simultaneously have realized is
that
over the last say 10 or 15 years there
has been a creep of
complexity so when you have
dozens of different entities
llc's and so on when you have
hundreds
or at least 100 different investments
and funds and capital calls and this
that and the other thing
and you've added people to your
organization so you have more head count
there is a certain
amount of complexity that comes with
that so
while there are
a million emails i can i feel like i can
safely ignore there are certain others
from
whether it's a tax authority or
some registered agent or an employee
that i do feel like i should keep track
of or there will
there will ultimately be some
consequences
to ignoring those things and so
this is a very roundabout way of asking
how you have seen people
either
reframe the complexities so that it has
less of a
[Music]
fearful impact
on them or
and or reduce complexity
in a way that
lessens this sort of
internal drama that they experience
going along with it
i love the way you frame that question
and um
[Music]
there are tips and tricks and hacks that
you can do to reduce the complexity
but
the complexity will creep back
and i think you know this because you've
experienced this and we've had
confidence
about that tension between those two
spaces
i hire an assistant and then all of a
sudden i need to
and then i need five
and now they need to be responded to
right
and it goes and so
let's take us all the way back to one of
jerry's very very famous questions which
is how have i been complicit in creating
the conditions i say i don't want
i like that you just referred to
yourself like the hulk uses
a third person
hulk mod
smash jerry ask jerry ask a question
that caused here
um how am i complicit in creating the
conditions i say i don't want right and
so i'm gonna
alter that just slightly what benefit do
i get
from the conditions i say i don't want
what benefit do i get
from the conditions i say i don't want
and so let's turn it back to the
question so you create these really
complex structures
and you probably spend an enormous
amount of energy
sorting them out responding them maybe
even use autoresponders tax person go
here kind of thing
so if you want to alter that behavior
you have to understand what the benefit
is to you right the payoff or the
secondary payoff that's it what's the
secondary payoff what's the secondary
benefit and for you
what does it make you feel like living a
very complex life with hundreds of
investments and lots of fingers and
multiple pies and doing all sorts of
things what does it do for you
so
i've i've thought about this and i would
say that i think the
complex structures are a side effect of
something else i don't think that i
actually get much payoff from the
complicated structures but i think
they're a symptom
and i would say
that for much of my life i had
competitive athletics and other things
that consumed in a very good way i think
a lot of my focus and provided a lot of
excitement
just as important
excitement and
i haven't had that in a very long time
after a shoulder reconstruction and then
elbow surgery and
twisted this eye joint and all these
things i'm like you know what maybe i
don't need to get heel hooked today
maybe i don't need to get thrown on my
head in judo class this week
and i've stopped a lot of that
and i think in lieu
of that i enjoy competition
i enjoy it and i don't think there's
anything inherently wrong with that
i actually really really enjoy
competition and i think i'm a good
competitor in a lot of ways
so i've shifted the arena from sports
and all these other things art although
i haven't treated art competitively but
these activities and
substituted in
investing
and i've substituted in
uh different types of projects that
often have some creative component
almost always they do whether it's deal
structuring or a podcast episode or a
pre-loading podcast that i can do a b
and c elsewhere but very often i would
say the the investing side in particular
is related
to excitement
i i would say that's what i get from it
and the side effect of having
lots of investments
and lots of
things that come along with that
is this complication the complexity and
the systems that makes sense to me
what's the opposite of excitement
the opposite of excitement would be
boredom which is why i wrote down this
hot and cold boredom for you
that you mentioned earlier i think it's
boredom i think it's
and i'm not you know i used to be more
maybe optimistic about this
i mean i am sure fundamentally it comes
down to
not wanting to be alone with my own
thoughts and certain feelings that might
come up right
uh so the question of you know what is
it that you're unwilling to feel
yeah i think it was tara barack who said
you know one sage said there's only one
question that matters what are you
unwilling to feel
and i've spent a lot of time thinking
about that i've spent a lot of time
working on that and i've also
arrived at a point where i'm i i've
looked at my family and i went to a
family wedding recently and i'm like
okay this could all be nurture maybe
it's just
behaviors that have been passed down the
bloodline
that's one
explanation it could also be that our
code
our dna just leads us to have a certain
baseline of
anxiety or depression or any number of
other things and
maybe i'm exerting a lot of calories
trying to
prove to myself that that is not the
case
you know tim
the thing that occurs to me every time
we talk is how much self work you've
done
and i'm going to make you feel really
uncomfortable because i'm really [ __ ]
proud of you
thank you jerry
you go there
so we're gonna go there
uh it you know the the proclivity to
anxiety could have a genetic component
here but the proclivity to be
uncomfortable with what the buddhist
would call hot
boredom
is not dna
it's you know to use the term from my
first book it's a subroutine
it's programming
it's nurture
and
you said
kind of offhand but really with a kind
of self-awareness
okay so i'm uncomfortable perhaps with
boredom because i don't like to
necessarily be alone with my own
thoughts
or to to face those things
and god bless you you've done a
fantastic job of learning to deal with
your own thoughts
so let's imagine if you will that the
learned behavior was boredom bad
hulk boredom bad
well the learned behavior may just as
equally have been the family saying we
don't want to actually be
with these questions
we don't want to be alone with our
thoughts collectively
because when we're alone with our
thoughts bad things happen
so let's get busy
yep and let's
make sure that we're
competitive and complicated and busy
with lots and lots of different things
so that we don't have to feel those
things over here
to to go back to tara brock
family systems
can reject
feelings
not just individuals
yep
right it reminds me about i i remember
sitting with a group of uh executives at
a company and
they asked me to just observe their
executive team and i was watching and
something came up it happened once it
happened twice it happened the third
time and what it was was anytime that
there was a really moment of tension
somebody would make a joke
and the whole energy would dissipate
and when i called it out the ceo said
that's just like my sunday afternoon
family dinners
and
sometimes
we get really complicated and busy
because we don't actually want to feel
what those thoughts
bring up
and there again is a reason why
sabbatical can feel really challenging
you